des gestes précis et rapides à quelques
jours des fêtes de fin d'année CIN
trancheurs de la pisculture de Villette
s'affaire pour préparer les saumons salé
fumé pendant 24 heur et tranché sur
place un rythme soutenu pour satisfaire
un carnet de commande bien rempli plus
de la moitié de la production annuelle
de ces poissons est réalisé durant le
mois de décembre on fume au moins 50 kg
par semaine toute l'année et en ce
moment évidemment c'est plutôt 50 kg par
jour suivant le taille du saumon on va
faire des tranches plus ou moins grandes
et puis on va les calibrer par exemple
là je suis en train de les calibrer à 45
g pour faire des tranches pas trop
grosses ce qui permet de faire des
plaques de 10 tranches par exemple qui
sont pas trop copieuses le saumon
provient des îles ferroé en Europe du
Nord contrairement à la truite ce
produit phare de la pisculture de
Villettes est élevé sur place dans ces
bassins de plus de 120 ans nourri
principalement à base d'insectes on
retrouve ici des variétés comme la
truite arc-en-ciel fario ou jaune nous
allons un matin les les abattre ces
poissons sont très rapidement dans les
minutes qui suivent et visérés au ciseau
ensuite plongés dans de l'eau salée donc
une saumure pendant quelques heur et
ensuite suspendu à un crochet en inox et
accroché à des gris qui vont en chambre
froide pour se reposer pendant minimum
24 he pour que la chair se détend dans
ce grand four 240 truites sont fumées
grâce à cette sour de bois de être une
cuisson d'une heure à 150° plus de 2000
sachets de ces produits sont conçus pour
les fêtes une activité réalisée sur le
site depuis 10 947 je ve prends le
poisson le plus gros et la petite astuce
ça va être d'aller voir à cœur s'il
reste du sang et si le sang est cuit ou
pas je vais essayer de décoller
gentiment la colonne vertébrale de la
chair on voit le long de la colonne
vertébrale un liseret légèrement
marronné ce qui veut dire que le sang à
cœur du poisson a été cuit dans la
vallée de la veau couleur la pisculture
de Villette est installée depuis
1896 poisson entier tranché en riette ou
en soupe de nombreux articles sont
disponibles dans la boutique sur place
compte 82 € le kilo pour des tranches de
saumon fumé et 4,80 € pièces pour une
truite fumée de 150 g de quoi combler
les papis des convives les plus
exigeants durant vos repas de fête